yeah welcome to this video playing a
goon international master Alan Helen
from Norway again and I think she's
really from Norway and then hung his
auto probably butchering this
pronunciation terribly she's on on icc
for ages also and tweaked utter rout
lopez let's see what light she's
choosing I always hoped for for this
Bishop e7 and the very conventional main
lines because I play them myself ok so
maybe the UM the Marshall was possible I
played h3 to prevent it and now we
transpose to a regular Breyer variation
one of the very main lines of this
opening it's a very very playable line
for black that are always intended to
learn but never got to yeah like a
four-eyed a 4 C 5 this this kind of
setup
yeah I'm not sure this maybe this is
maybe one of the absolute main lines of
this opening I know that the main line
is looking somewhat like this maybe not
exactly like this but various
similarities
yeah h5 hmm yep this this some in this
kind of position there are many many
ideas f4 is one of them or play on the a
file of course played this first maybe
intending who gate okay she just broke
this pin yeah why not
k still maybe I'm the queen gets a
misplaced somewhat with queen aid or
screen to a to a viable plan maybe it is
yeah I want to prepare a form besides f4
I don't really know one and we're
playing in this position
oh this is so interesting tactic for
take on age 4 she's going to take on e4
wait is this really working there's also
d6 hanging maybe 95 but this was not so
clear if this is helping 94 94 bishop
age for the sd-6 a and 94 94 94 rookie
for keeps age for protected if she takes
d5 the rook g-form yes but this this is
not clear at all i can do various things
here can do i can take e 7 and take d 6
which is not bad well not bad as an
understatement that's probably very good
for white and I can also consider taking
on d5 bishop age four and then some move
like night f5 just attacking but ok this
is this is probably a simple and good
she cannot take afford sufficiently
protected and that c5 hanging 'if I've
hanging so what does black doing there's
also Knight g4 f 6 and 10 stuff y'know
chief form looks looks very strong
threatening four kinds of things Knight
f6 Queenie 596 that's just no move h4
was an interesting technical idea but I
think it didn't just didn't work um yeah
Knight f6 king king needs to go
somewhere somewhere bad now queen here
Queen h6 coming
black reason yeah it's it's too much
King g7 I can do a queen g5 and Evan
have a deadly attack now also he ate is
hanging nonsense yeah deadly attack this
is also true i mean queen g5s is also
winning but of course can just just take
this was checkin tanned and it's over
yeah h4 is not working probably i think
it is a known known idea but it's not
it's not on the computer actually wants
to go Queen a2 with unclear oh well now
it gives widen advantage but yeah this
was more simple simple and good yeah
good plus five plus five is quite good
yeah okay if thanks for watching this
this good game